watch out world have i got news for you
that's right this is rory scoville
comedian dad
artist and i've got a new podcast with
ruthie wyatt on team coco called
dads the podcast very clever name
you're already hooked it's a show for
dads and
non-dads so if you're not a dad get
right back over here
each week we are joined by some of my
favorite people we talk about parenting
fatherhood and the men that made us the
strange human beings
we are today i mean i see now with my
son
he really got into the simpsons a couple
years ago before he really knew that i
had worked there
and then one day an episode came up and
he saw my name on it
oh i could see the nickel drop and he
was looked at me like
oh he's not a total waste of space
i mean the beauty i think of being queer
going into your journey into parenting
is like
in the beginning i thought this was
going to be like such a sad part of my
life like trying to find a baby and in
the end it was like finding your destiny
oh i saw her like for the first time two
weeks ago
you know going so if i text stacy right
now and ask her if she gave you baths
she'd say she gave you a bath yeah
is it strangely prideful i was just
thrilled that she didn't want to take a
bath
good primal i remember when my son was
two
he had a toy and i was just like oh no
no no we don't put things in our butt
unless
well you you know life is so
crazy oliver and and then he's like 18.
he's like i don't know i've always felt
shame about water yeah
because of my mother so i took him out
to jamba juice for father's day
so we're like standing in line he's
telling me this like story about
his dad and he was like that man lived
99 years
and not once did he ever say i love you
and then my dad goes
i'll have a razzmatazz with immunity
boost
there it is folks the proof that was
conan o'brien sabrina jalisce
david cross vanessa ragland justin
halpern
these are just a few of the amazing
guests and amazing conversations that
you're gonna get
on dad's the podcast our first episode
is gonna be dropping on september 2nd
are you gonna be there subscribe do not
miss this do not
[Music]
you